[Music]
today's question comes from sabrina in
new jersey sabrina writes i listen to
dave and agree with most of his views oh
this is going to be awesome i love these
me too sabrina me too
i listen to dave and agree with most of
his views but not on sharing bank
accounts with your spouse
i like steve harvey's advice to share a
bank account for the bills and then have
one for yourself and one for the other
spouse
i see couples fighting all the time
about what the other spends money on
my sister and her husband argue about
the way she buys her coffee
i'm engaged to be married to my fiance
and i don't want the same things when it
comes to finances how can we avoid that
i think your sister's married to a jerk
he gets mad about how she buys her
coffee what does that even mean unless
they are broke and she's ordering nine
dollar
double latte expression
i literally had in my head that they're
at the coffee shop and she's ordering
he's like why would you do that why
would you put it i'll probably just take
how expensive it is
i like went to like the order not
specifically the price so that's fair so
here's the thing to answer this question
i'm engaged to be married to my fiance
and i don't
want the same things we don't want the
same things when it comes to finances
how can we avoid that don't get married
really
right or does that not with the same
things like her sister has
no
she is engaged to be married and her
fiancee and i don't want the same thing
when it comes to finance right um
either don't get married or have some
hard conversations and get on the same
page because yeah i'll let you rachel
what do you think
you're always telling people to share
bank accounts yeah always because in my
head
yeah you see couples fighting all the
time about the way the other spends
their money and to me
that's not just a money issue it's not a
money issue at all like we go back to i
mean it's a it's a marriage thing are
you guys on the same team are you
working towards the same goals yeah to
your point are y'all trying to get out
of debt and one's spending money over
here
when they shouldn't be well that's less
about again the dollars and cents in my
head and that's more about respecting
each other and the plan that you're on
and working as a team to get like that's
a whole other conversation it's coming
out
that way
and then my other thing too is when
people avoid because i hear this a lot
well
people fight a lot about money so it's
just not worth it it's easier to have
separate accounts
because if we had the same accounts then
we would fight about money and like well
then the fights that
you would have are the fights you you
should be having those are the
conversations you gotta have then you
gotta have those confirmations you can't
just avoid hard topics in marriage by
putting a band-aid and having separate
accounts like it just doesn't it doesn't
work and to steve harvey i've heard i've
seen the clips
of him and i'm like in my head
having the same account where you each
still have your own spending money of
course there's a rachel line item in our
budget there's a winston line item even
our kids they each have their own line
item because it just makes things easier
like here where are we at with you guys
in spending in the month and so
i still have the freedom i'm like i
still have my i d i'm still rachel and i
still i'm gonna enjoy spending things on
on things that winston could care less
about winston spends money on stuff that
i don't really care about but but i'm
like hey we we both agree this is the
amount of money so to me regardless of
whether it's in a separate checking
account
or not to me that or the same you still
have the idea that you still have money
to spend individually right and the idea
that if you put it together then you
lose
any of the things that you would ever
want any of your autonomy it's nonsense
yeah it means you have to have a shared
conversation about shared goals yeah
right roommates have separate accounts
couples who are together for the long
haul
walk through things man they work
together
so if you're married
have one account and if conflict comes
up because of it good then you're gonna
work through it so let's let's let's
pull us apart for a second sabrina
when you ask when you say that you and
your fiance don't want the same things
when it comes to finances
as a guy who works with couples this is
a big red flag not because of the money
but because somebody wants to have a lot
of cars to work on in the driveway
somebody wants a home
somebody wants um to retire someday
somebody wants fill in a blank these are
questions about how we're going to live
our lives what we're going to do
together and more importantly what we
value
and
that what finances is just the math part
of the what do we value question and so
you all have to get in a room and say do
we want to value peace and we want to
value laughing deeply and going on
vacations and enjoying our lives or do
we want to value
a suburban we can't afford and um
sending our kids to college is that
they've got to mortgage their souls for
whatever the question whatever values
y'all come up with that's the question
and that's your finance is a line after
the values question yep absolutely